very quick reminder 24 hours left to get  your submissions in for the free  membership contest Patrick Ferreira came  to me with a proposal for a membership  giveaway the proposal is you submit some  kind of visual art related to the david  pakman show to instagram with the  hashtag david pakman show seventeen okay  let's put up the hashtag just to make  sure everybody knows exactly what it is  it can be anything related to the show a  comic a caricature of producer Pat an  interpretive an interpretive poem  related to Pat's Keurig usage whatever  right but the idea is it's art of some  kind and you tagged it on instagram with  david pakman show 17:5 people will be  selected tomorrow to receive a free  one-year membership you can also follow  me and tag me there i'm on instagram at  david pakman